And the sons of Noah that went forth of the Ark were Shem and ham and Japheth.
And Ham is the father of Canaan.
These are the three sons of Noah and of them was the whole earth.
Overspread and Noah began to be a HUD husbands men.
And he planted a vineyard and he drank of the wine and was drunk.
And,
and he was uncovered within his tent and Ham.
The father of Canaan saw the nakedness of his father and told his two brethren
without,
and Shem,
and Japheth took a garment and laid upon both their shoulders and went backward
and covered the nakedness of their father.
And their faces were backward,
and they saw not their father's nakedness.
And Noah awoke from his wine and knew what his younger son had done unto him.
And he said,
curse had to be Canaan,
a servant of servants shall he be unto his brethren.
And he said,
blessed shall be the Lord God of Shaman.
Canaan shall be his servant,
and God shall enlarge Japheth.
And he shall dwell in the tents of Shem.
And Canaan shall be his servant.
And Noah lived after the flood,
350 years and all the days of Noah were 950 years and he died
and the whole earth was of one language and of one speech.
Okay.
So
I remember thinking about this story,
it's gotta be 30 years ago
and I think the meaning of the story stood out for me.
Sometimes when you read complicated materials,
sometimes a piece of it will stand out.
It's for some reason it's like it glitters.
I suppose that might be one way of thinking about it.
It's it,
you're in sync with it and you can understand what it means.
I've really experienced that reading the Tao Te Ching,
which is document I would really like to do a lecture on at some point because
some of the verses I don't understand,
but others stand right out and I can understand them.
And I think I understood what this part of the story of Noah meant.
And I think it means,
you know,
we talked a little bit about what nakedness meant in the story of Adam and eve.
And the idea essentially was that to know yourself naked is to become aware of
your vulnerability,
the physical,
your physical boundaries in time and space and your,
your,
your physiological,
your fundamental physiological insufficiencies as they meet might be judged by
others.
So there's biological insufficiency that sort of built into you because you're a
fragile mortal,
vulnerable half insane creature.
And that's,
that's just an existential truth.
And then of course,
even merely as a human being,
even with all those faults,
there are faults that you have that are particular to you that might be judged
harshly by the group while might be,
we'll definitely be judged harshly by the group.
And so to become aware of your nakedness is to become self conscious and to,
and to,
to know your limits and to know vulnerability.
And that's what is revealed to him when he comes across as farther naked.
It's so the question is what does it mean to see your father naked?
And it seems to me,
and especially in an inappropriate manner like this,
it,
it's,
it's as if ham,
he does the same thing that happens in the Mesopotamian creation myth.
When when tie him out an absolute give rise to the first God's there,
they're the father of the eventual day of redemption.
Marduk they're very careless and noisy and the kill appsu their father and
attempt to inhabit his corpse.
And that makes timeout enraged.
And so she bursts forth from the darkness to,
to do the men.
It's like a precursor to the flood story or an analog to the flood story.
And I see the same thing happening here with him is that he's,
he's insufficiently respectful of his father.
And the question is exactly what does the farther represent.
And you could say,
well,
there's,
there's the father that you have and that's a human being.
That's,
that's a man like other men,
a man among men.
But then there's the farther as such.
And that's the spirit of the father.
And insofar as you have a father,
you have both at the same time.
You have the personal father that's a man among other men just like anyone else
who's father.
But insofar as that man is your father,
that means that he's something different than just another person.
And what he is is the incarnation of the spirit of the father.
And to see that,
to take it to what,
to disrespect that carelessly,
maybe even he like,
no,
it makes a mistake,
right?
He
produces wine and gets himself drunk.
And you might say,
well,
you know,
if he's sprawled out there for everyone to see,
it's hardly hams fault if he stumbles across him.
But the book is laying out a danger and the danger is that,
well maybe you catch your father at his most vulnerable moment and if you're
disrespectful then you transgress against the spirit of the father.
And if you transgress against the spirit of farther and Louis Spirit of the
father and lose respect for the spirit of the father,
then that is likely to transform you into a slave.
That's a very interesting idea and I think it's particularly interesting.
Maybe not particularly interesting,
but it's,
it's particularly Germane,
I think,
to our current cultural situation because I think that we're pushed constantly
to see the nakedness of our father,
so to speak,
because of the intense criticism that's directed towards our culture and the
patriarchal culture,
so to speak.
We're constantly exposing its weaknesses and vulnerabilities and let's say
nakedness,
and
there's wrong with criticism,
but the thing about criticism is the purpose of criticism is to separate the
wheat from the chaff.
It's not the burn everything to the ground,
right?
It's to say,
well,
we're going to carefully look at this.
We're going to carefully differentiate.
We're going to keep what's good and we're going to move away from what's bad,
but the point of the criticism isn't to identify everything is bad.
It's two separate.
What's good from what's bad so that you can retain what's good and move towards
it,
and to be careless at that is is deadly because you're inhabited by the spirit
of the father,
right?
In so far as you're a cultural construction,
which of course is something that the,
that the postmodern,
Neo Marxists are absolutely enthusiastic about.
You're a cultural construction in so far as you're a cultural construction,
then your inhabited by the spirit of the father.
And to be disrespectful towards that means to undermine the very structure that
makes you not all of what you are.
Certainly certainly not all of what you are,
but a good portion of what you are in,
in so far as you're a socialized cultural entity.
And if you pull out the,
if you pull the foundation out from underneath that,
what do you have left it,
you can hardly manage on your own.
You know,
it's just not possible.
You're a cultural creation.
And so Hamm makes this desperate error and is careless about exposing himself to
the vulnerability of his father or something like that.
He does it without sufficient respect.
And the judgment is that not only will he be asleep,
but so all of his descendants and he's contracted with the other two sons who
I suppose are willing to give their father the benefit of the doubt,
something like that.
And so when they see him in a compromising position,
they handle it with respect and,
and,
and don't capitalize on it.
And,
and maybe that makes them strong.
That's what it seems to me.
And so I think that's what that story means.
It has something to do with respect.
You know?
And the funny thing about having respect for your culture,
and I suppose that's partly why I'm doing the biblical stories,
is because they're part of,
they're part of my culture.
They're part of our culture perhaps.
But there they're certainly part of my culture and it seems to me that
it's worthwhile to treat that with respect to see what you can glean from it
and,
and not kick it when it's down,
let's say.
So.
And so that's how the story of no ends,
you know?
And the thing too is Noah is actually a pretty decent incarnation of the spirit
of the father.
That,
which I suppose is one of the things that makes Hams misstep more egregious is
that,
I mean,
Noah just built an ark and got everybody through the flood.
Man,
you know,
it's not so bad in.
So maybe the fact that he happened to drink too much wine one day wasn't enough
to justify humiliating him.
And you know,
I don't think it's pushing the limits of symbolic interpretation to note on a
daily basis that were all contained in an arc.
Right?
And that's the arc that you could think about that as the arc that's been
bequeathed to us by our forefathers.
That's the tremendous infrastructure that we inhabit,
that we take for granted because it works so well that protects us from things
that we can't even imagine.
And we don't have to imagine because we're so well protected.
And so one of the things that's really struck me hard,
I would say about the disintegration and corruption of the universities is the
absolute in gratitude that goes along with that.
Criticism,
as I said,
is for fine thing,
if it's done in the spirit in a proper spirit,
and that's the spirit of separating the wheat from the chaff.
But it needs to be accompanied by gratitude.
And it does seem to me that anyone who lives in the west,
in the western culture at this time,
in history and in this place and who isn't simultaneously grateful for that is,
is,
is half blind at least because it's never been better than this.
And it could be so much worse and it's highly likely that it will be so much
worse because for most of human history,
so much worse is the norm.